yeah welcome to this video playing the
00 or double zero or whatever yeah Carol
Conant I'll go further Bronstein large
and once again let's see okay rather
modest set up by white black gum doesn't
have any particular problems and
developing okay let's win this temple
don't really mind this exchange Queen B
6 no queen e five Queen a5 b5 might be
an idea and Queen a5 also um irritate
some may be a bit okay wants to wants to
play an ID see form
94 I go Bishop e7 at the Knight b6 yeah
and this is what I was hoping for I
thought this would be rather interesting
structure for black would life be 625
being the idea how king is seven oz
interesting i'm not sure about this but
it lets in its it leads to to a an
unconventional position he can take but
I don't think it's it's so great that's
not bad I mean but it's not like he's
fielding this idea by taking on d6 idea
is an ID 5 rook c8 before something like
that wait I'll make where I want to go
ok I can't go to the sim it's not a big
deal so I'd like to get rid of the H
porn the capture is not not a problem
yes
hmm gap what about B form okay moves the
bishop and then it's before one idea
before or whatever has a tech first now
we cannot take with the f porn because
if h3 was so saying I'm wondering what
do I can take that can play this of
course c4 that's 93 end up picking up
the pond and then this is very strong
actually if you cannot place here for
you will get a week porn on the C file
yeah or this one so true time yeah this
is just good
okay yeah the Sun looks like a very
comfortable endgame for black he's got
this week default porn and I'm
centralized he cannot go really kinky
too because of Roxy too kinky wonder sir
the only move OIC thinking okay night
yep just backin this is a good blockade
yeah this is probably the best way how
to continue now taking looks you form
something like that I do I'm and let's
let's wait for moto taking on HHS is not
great anyway at what to see playing
actually I'm not not so sure how to
continue it's very nice but how to
continue
maybe I should actually think about 97
and f5 maybe or this one had this one f5
using the somewhat unstable position of
this bishop this could be an idea rook
c1 or something isn't helping in any way
of c7 I have nicely covered so I'm
threatening Wow okay i will have who i'm
just threatening ruka h89 you need to
move it again you can only go to f2 and
then root gauge a data wind eh from and
now I can take and play a fri view but
is this sis good Ed's not bear to come
on let's let's do this
it's got some stranger time management
maybe maybe it's got some connection
issue yeah okay to go back
but how does he protect you for now I
don't really see you can play rook rook
age fri could have played but then i can
take an ID f6 so just just to grabbing
this now or maybe just this one so that
he cannot even activate the rook rook
takes rook takes it's probably not much
of a difference anyway 95 no he's still
got 95 is the god look check and look to
be aide who should i go to d7 maybe
oh I didn't really think about that
hmm how annoying I really are allowed
him far too much counterplay far too
much then then then the necessary rooks
e6 and whatever what a shame okay sexy
edits even though it's even a big threat
unbelievable
yeah I couldn't should have just taken
this the stupid ass stupid porn right
away and have been much better check
check check check check check check
check check check check mate oh ok gaba
dad I really played this badly he was
completely busted and I really allowed
far too much far too much here I mean
this is just just just winning for black
and nothing else I only need to be
precise which I completely failed to be
I should just take it now I mean just
grab it I didn't I didn't want to think
about this but it's it's it's really not
a big deal yeah this is the problem this
Bishop is strapped actually I cannot go
anywhere this is have six where do you
go now it's quite embarrassing this
check is just King c6 yeah I didn't seek
a root G 2 and this is why I went went
for this and this is yeah this this is
already slightly tricky here pretty I
just I just need to take G for what a
pretty good game before that
alright thanks for watching